I'm told that Aubry from Wisconsin's
microphone is fixed let's see if that is
true Aubry from Wisconsin welcome to the
program let's see if we can make it
happen this time can you hear me this
time yes I can Aubry welcome back okay
hi David
um thank you I'm So Sorry my phone's
like schizo okay please don't swear
because as as I've told you during all
of your previous phone calls we have to
bleep when you swear for our radio
Affiliates thank you
[Laughter]
daily apologize
I could hear it you're like mad at me
right now no I'm curious what you're
bringing to me today because you do you
do Broach interesting topics yeah yeah
yeah okay I was going to a Munch end to
you about like filters and stuff but I
don't
want to I want to talk about I wanna I
have okay sorry
um what is your take on America and
Israel right because like right now
America and what ethereal
Israel Israel Israel the country of
Israel
hello yeah because this happened like a
week ago I wanted to ask you this yeah
can you hear me yes I can okay cool cool
okay yeah because this happened like a
week ago and I was like commuted on your
server actually because me and I started
someone got an argument I'm not gonna
get into it she was very rude to me
anyways um so this like
um happened a week ago they were like
they like um bombed a military
um uh weapons whatever in Iran and like
if this was like any other country this
would start World War III but you know
because it's sweet baby Israel America
didn't care because you know we pumped
them up with money and I'm a proud
Palestinian Lebanese woman
um as you can see like you know am I pfp
I'm like you know an Arab girl
um so that like you know I just like 13c
or take like do you think that like
America will ever stop pumping Israel
with money or do you think that like you
know they're just gonna take over the
entirety of Palestine and you know do
everything or whatever the heck they
want that's what I said I said the heck
I didn't say anything
um Aubry you know you've broached such a
massive issue which is the
israeli-palestinian conflict
so I have the right to say it oh I
didn't I'm not questioning you're right
I'm just saying I couldn't possibly
thoroughly respond to what you're saying
in this format but what I do want to
tell you is that I have dozens of videos
with what I believe is the only real
credible path to peace in the Middle
East on my YouTube channel and I outline
it in detail including what I believe
the borders would be what I believe
leadership on both sides would have to
look like
Etc and so I would recommend checking
out some of some of those segments I
think but do you think it's crazy that
they're able to just
probably leave Aubry Aubry Aubry you're
you're swearing completely
uncontrollably okay
let's see if we can simmer the situation
a little bit
um I believe that a two-state solution
is the only likely path to peace I don't
know that I believe current leadership
on either side is credibly going to get
us there and I encourage you to check
out my material on on the YouTube
channel about it
okay thank you all right thank you and
Aubry remind us you're not from Long
Island right
I'm in Wisconsin okay very good all
right Aubry great to hear from you I
appreciate it thank you have a great day
me too there goes Aubry from Wisconsin
let's take just a very quick break to
recover from that and once we've
reconstituted our energy we're going to
come right back and take more calls so
if you are waiting on the Discord please
don't hang up we'll be right back to it